it will be working
so before I start the programming by the
launch door I have to connect the cables
here
under the dashboard I open the dashboard
first then I connect the cable is here
the black color is on the yellow
and the red color is on the purple like
a mixed colors on there
okay so and I fix everything now I'm
going to make the first I need to read
the code PIN code
okay so I'm going to write the PIN code
first
okay
switch ignition on and open the hazard
light okay
okay
there is only one key now
I'm trading the PIN code
mistake time like a
like a one minute or something
Distributing the code so the important
things is you fix this cable is properly
here
that is the important things
okay
the code is still loading
[Music]
it should be not take time that much but
I don't know what's happening
yes what is reading this is the code
okay Enter now I'm going to make the
program case
okay switch ignition off it is off
already as it is on okay
there is one key only now
put the smart key to reprogram it
this is the one I'm going to program it
put it into the Super placement key we
program it inside the car take others
okay
afternoon press the start button
press the cut start button adjustment
key you can end by this one
okay
to press this by like that
just keep it on the pressing
this way
is his success
no it's felt
I'm going to try it again
okay
please check there is another Wireless
near to the smart key device okay
is the corrected button and the smart
key
turn the link into this
let's try it again
it should be take the first name but I
don't always feel they have to try it
again
it's filed
let's try again
okay
that's just the chicken
maybe the way I putting it is wrong this
way just giving the fill
and let's try it again and again
I don't know
[Music]
I think I know the problem
okay
and I think you need to put the key
First Press
then okay
press the button okay yeah I know it's
accurate so before I was trying to the
wrong way that's why it's not success
but no success now the talk is there
program is completed
it means that need to press key first
then enter down the device
success okay
thank you guys for watching my video
thank you